bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment vous
accueillez cette mesure un bon jour et
ben écoutez cette mesure nous ce qu'on
est on est préoccupée surtout par com
comment dans quelles conditions vont
pouvoir reprendre les transports du
point de vue bien évidemment des
salariés mais aussi des usagers quand on
impose aujourd'hui le port du masque
dans les transports il faut aussi
s'assurer que les gens ont les moyens
déjà premièrement d'avoir un masque et
quel type de masque voilà les questions
qu'on pose aujourd'hui nous sur
l'application de cette mesure à la sncf
dans les transports et les gars est ce
que ce sera possible baisse et c'est
tout l'enjeu des réponses que doit
fournir le gouvernement aujourd'hui aux
gens qui vont faire rouler les trains et
aux gens qui vont les emprunter nous on
dit en tant que syndicat qui protège
évidemment bien sûr ses salariés dans
l'exercice de toutes leurs missions qui
sont vraiment diverses à la sncm c'est
des masques ffp2 c'est du gel
hydroalcoolique
c'est des lingettes virucide c'est la
possibilité de se laver les mains
régulièrement c'est la mise en
application des gestes barrières tel
qu'on nous les présente aujourd'hui donc
dans quelles conditions ces les
questions qui sont posées aujourd'hui je
précise qu'après la fin du confinement
le masque sera obligatoire durant au
moins trois semaines
est ce que c'est un délai suffisant
bains où sont les masques qui les
distribuent à quel prix
comment on fait quand on n'a pas les
moyens de s'en procurer que ce soit
financier ou matériel ou dans la journée
les employeurs comment ils font pour
s'assurer que ses respectés et puis dans
les transports enfin écoutez moi je veux
bien
je suis un usager des transports
quotidiens le bus le rer le métro je
sais pas comment on peut faire respecter
aujourd'hui un mètre est qui et qui
surtout sera amené à verbaliser à faire
respecter aujourd'hui comment on fait
comment ça se passe pour protéger les
usagers mais aussi les employés
et bien aujourd'hui ce qui est trés
déficit s'est visiblement c'est de se
procurer le matériel j'entendais hier le
président jean pierre farandou qui
disait aux gens les mains jointes
venez à vote avec votre masque quasiment
pour rentrer dans une gare est encore
bien évidemment dans un train donc
aujourd'hui je me demande aujourd'hui la
personne qui va aller travailler ou qui
contrainte d'aller travailler bien sûr
comme m6 il a pas la possibilité ce
progrès un masque comment il fait quand
on vous entend on envie de vous poser
cette question est ce que pour vous
cette date du 11 mai elle pose un
problème
nous nous on n'a pas décidé de la date
nous déjà en plus on nous dit le 11 mai
mais on dira le 7 mai s'il ya le 11 mai
donc c'est ça qu'on a entendu pour
l'instant on a l'impression que ça fait
quand même allé près plus d'un mois et
demi que nous sommes en période de
confinement et aujourd'hui on se pose la
question de comment on va organiser le
déconfinement je pense qu'il ya quand
même des sujets qui qui devrait avancer
et si on n'avance pas il faut prendre le
temps justement de réfléchir à comment
on fait pour pas faire vite vite et
n'importe quoi et en tout cas pour
respecter la santé de tous
nous on sera attentif et ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est si les conditions ne
sont pas réunies pour prendre les
transports ont dit aux usagers
fait fait ce qu'il faut pour ne pas
faire ne pas prendre les transports
idem pour les salariés le salarié
aujourd'hui s'ils reprennent le travail
c'est dans des conditions dans
lesquelles leur santé préserver et
s'agissant du trafic après le 11 mai à
votre avis comment les choses là encore
on se passer écoutez graphique alors là
on a une vision complètement noir enfin
on sait pas on marche un petit peu a vu
comment on va s'organiser le système de
réservation tout en préservant justement
des distance suffisante dans les trains
comment va s'organiser la fréquence tout
en gérant bas de toute façon les
ressources dans personnel quand en
circulation comment allons-nous faire
comment nous faire repartir un service
optimal moi j'en sais rien c'est
aujourd'hui c'est on nous annonce une
reprise sans sans nous sans s'assurer
qu'on sera dans des conditions de toute
sécurité pour faire rouler les trains
alors la fréquence je vous dire ça vient
en second plan je pense
merci beaucoup christophe prat âge
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
fédéral fo cheminots fo